the Bible
frankly the Bible is my favorite book my
second favorite book I always say is art
of the deal of course with the Bible as
my first favorite book I love the Bible
okay the old testament the new I've
reached so many Testaments people they
say Trump's he's the Testament King with
all the Testaments I'm frankly reading
all the time
I have many Bibles I have them I keep
them in a very special place I keep them
I laminate sometimes even the Bibles I
laminate them Chris I take the Bibles
and I let the guy down at the lamination
shop he takes my clothes I say have
another Bible to laminate he frankly
I've made him a millionaire truthfully
five times over with all the Bible's
that I have had laminated so truthfully
if I were to get to heaven
I think that say Peter say Christopher
whoever's working the gate that day
because it would depend on who I want
working the gate I have my connections
that I could say hey I want this guy at
the gate I think they would say hey you
had so many Bibles and you treated them
so well we want you to come in but I
would come in and I tell you what I
would there is so much untapped
potential in have it I would go in we'd
have gold we'd have if they have streaks
of gold we would do some we would do
something else maybe we make them silt
maybe we make the platinum I don't know
but I would I would tap heaven and
nobody else would talk about about what
they could do in heaven with their and
it because of all my frankly all my
laminated Bibles click here to hear me
answer your questions frankly about
Mexico
you